en esta ocasión compararemos estos dos
números 9.97 y tenemos también 9.798 lo
que buscaremos es saber cuál es más
grande o mayor que el otro y para eso lo
que haremos es analizar cada valor
posicional en ambos números y después
recorrer nos hacia los más pequeños para
saber cuál es la diferencia entre ambos
y esto va a ser muy muy rápido tenemos 9
en el valor posicional más grande
de la misma manera que aquí tenemos 9
así es que se ve se ve similar entramos
en la zona de los decimales y cambiar el
color el valor posicional siguiente a
las unidades en este caso son los
décimos o décimas y en este caso tenemos
9 en el valor de las décimas con un 7
y aquí ya podemos saber oye el número de
la izquierda es más grande porque porque
el valor posicional de las décimas tiene
una diferencia donde el 9 es mayor que
el 7 y tal vez no puedas decir oye pero
todavía faltan números hacia la derecha
tenemos un 7 aquí y tenemos un 98 acá
sí pero no importa de hecho aquí puedes
incrementar los números cuanto quieras
sin embargo aquí dado el valor
posicional tenemos ya una diferencia y
recuerda siempre el valor posicional
mayor es el de la izquierda en este caso
este es exactamente igual que este pero
aquí hay una diferencia podemos de
entrada ya saber que este es más grande
este número podrá crecer si sumamos
milésimos a 9.7 98 9.7 99
9.8
pero este 9.8 aún será menor que el 9.9
que ya tenemos aquí para que esto sea
más claro vamos a hacer la suma en
cuestión de fracciones para que sea
mucho más evidente entonces empecemos y
colocaremos los números de la siguiente
manera tenemos 9
más
9 decimos que son estos
y del otro lado tenemos también nueve
más
siete décimos
aquí se alcanza a ver ya qué
en la izquierda es mucho más grande pero
vamos a completar el resto de los
números para lograr la fracción total +
7 centésimos este 7 se encuentra en la
posición de los centésimos y vamos al
mismo valor posicional aquí tenemos en
la posición de los centésimos 9
centésimas
de este lado ya no tenemos más números
en los milésimos aquí si vamos a
colocarlo tenemos un 8 en la posición de
los mil décimos
y para lograr hacer esta suma vamos a
poner todos nuestros números en términos
de milésimos y con esto podremos sumarlo
así es que nueve son 9000
milésimos
multiplicamos ambos tanto numerador como
denominador por 1000
+ 9
decimos los multiplicaremos por 10 y
tendremos 90 centésimos y otra vez por
10 para tener 900 milésimas
finalmente vamos a sumar
7 centésimos y los multiplicaremos por
10 tanto el numerador como el
denominador para tenerlo en términos de
millésime os vamos con el número de al
lado tenemos 9000
milésimos
más
milésimos solo multiplicamos tanto
numerador como denominador por 100 más
milésimos aquí multiplicamos por 10 y
finalmente sumaremos los 8000
milésimos al hacer nuestra suma esto me
quedara algo sobre mí
y tenemos que 9 1970 es igual a 9000
70 de la misma manera haremos la suma de
este lado y algo nos quedará sobre 1000
nueve mil 709 mil 799 mil 790 más 89 mil
lo colocaremos aquí 9000
ahora sí
podemos hacer la comparativa tenemos
este mismo número en términos de
milésimos de la misma manera que tenemos
este en términos de milésimas 9.970
milésimos es más grande que nueve mil
798 milésimos así es que de cualquier
manera que ustedes lo vean
nos podemos dar cuenta que el número de
la izquierda es más grande lo vimos por
el valor posicional que tuvo una
diferencia e incluso al hacer la
representación de estos números en
términos de milésimas
logramos ver que este es mucho mayor que
este de la derecha
nos vemos en otro vídeo